-We're here with Ike Barinholtz.
And buddy, I'm very excited
because we worked together
way back in the day.
But it's been a long time
since we've collaborated
on a project and yet we both are
lucky enough to be voices
in the
"Batman Audio Adventure,"
which is a podcast available
through Max Originals.
You are the voice of Harvey
Dent, Two Face.
-Harvey Dent.
-And you did some deep,
deep preparation for the role.
-Yeah, I got a call from
Dennis McNiklas,
a friend of ours,
been a fan of his for a
long time and he was like,
I want you to play Two Face
and I was so excited
and you know, I'm this huge fan
of Batman and everything
since I was a kid and
I was like,
I'm going to take the initiative
of this,
and so I hired out-of-pocket,
a unbelievable
special affects make-up artist.
-Okay.
-Like, this lady is like the
next Rick Baker.
I mean, she is incredible.
And pricey.
And for about nine hours she did
a Two Face, right,
you know, one side --
you know Two Face,
one side's like handsome guy,
the other side is horrifying.
-Yeah. He famously
has two faces.
-He has two faces.
And I got all of my make-up
on and I had a special suit,
bespoke suit that is half
normal suit and half nuts.
And then I showed up
and I walk in, and I was like,
here, I do like, here I am!
And it was at that moment
I was like,
"Oh, my God, this is a podcast."
-Right.
-There's not even a God damn
camera in the room. Okay.
-Uh-huh.
-So I recorded the entire
podcast with this make-up on
for that one and the next two
and by the fourth one,
I was like,
I am just flushing money down
the toilet.
You know, I ended up spending
$12,000 of my own money
for a podcast.
To look cool for a podcast.
But with that said,
it is awesome if you are
a fan of Batman,
you have to check this out,
it is, and it has a crazy
cast too.
-It's a very good cast.
You know, it's interesting you
mentioned about Two Face's suit,
that does feel like overkill.
It felt like his face was severe
enough that if he just wore
the one suit, people would have
accepted he was a bad guy.
-Also, Two Face does not have
any skills as a tailor,
he's not gonna go into, like,
you know whatever,
Barney's or Niemanns and being
like, "Here's what I need.
I need two suits --
-He would be like this,
here's what I need,
because he would not want to
reveal that there was some --
-Yeah.
-Hi, can I help you, sir?
-Hello, yes, I'm looking for
a suit that's a little bit
unconventional.
-Okay.
-One half I want just a normal
Tom Ford type thing and
then on the other half,
I want
the scariest thing you have!
[ Laughter ]
-Very good, buddy.
-That was bone chilling.
That performance was
bone chilling.
-I'm very excited about
talking about good casts,
you are in a show coming up
called "White House Plumbers,"
which is about
the Watergate scandal
and just seems delightful.
-It's wonderful, we have got
my man Woody Harrelson,
and Justin Thereaux.
It is so tough acting with those
guys, 'cause they're so, like,
naturally lean.
And, then, like, I just like
walk up on that ceiling.
A big old water Buffalo, like
what's going over here?
Like, honestly compared to,
like, Thereaux I'm in a lot
of scenes with him, and I look
and sound like Sidney Powell.
Like -- it's not, it's not good.
I need to start working
with less attractive actors.
-This is not working out for me.
-I never thought about
the downside of working with
those who are naturally lean.
I feel like you should have that
in your rider
as something you are not
prepared to do.
-Yeah, I have a thing where I
have to personally approve
every actor that I work with and
they have to be at least
26% body fat, otherwise,
find somebody else, guys.
-Hey, buddy, congrats on
"Chicago Party,"
and thanks so much for being
here, I love you very much.
-Next time it's in person
and I am kissing you.
And I'm kissing everyone
in the crew.
-[ Laughs ] "Chicago Party Aunt"
is streaming now on Netflix.
By the way, Wally, Wally, come
over here and give me the card.
'Cause you were talking about
Latvia look how Wally
spelled the show,
"Chicago Aunt Party."
That's Latvia, Latvia Netflix.
Streaming on Netflix.